mathematical principles of natural
philosophy definitions definition 1 the
quantity of matter is the measure of the
same arising from its density and bulk
conjointly that's air of a double
density in a double space is quadruple
in quantity in a triple space 6 - belén
quantity the same thing is to be
understood of snow and fine dust or
powders that are condensed by
compression or liquefaction and of all
bodies that are by any causes whatever
differently condensed I have no regard
in this place to a medium if any such
there is that freely pervades the in
distances between the parts of bodies it
is this quantity that I mean hereafter
everywhere under the name of body or
mass and the same is known by the weight
of each body for it is proportional to
the weight as I have found by
experiments on pendulums very accurately
made which shall be shown here after
definition to the quantity of motion is
the measure of the same arising from the
velocity and quantity of matter
conjointly the motion of the whole is
the sum of the motions of all the parts
and therefore in a body double in
quantity with equal velocity the motion
is double with twice the velocity it is
quadruple
definition three the VIS and sita or
innate force of matter is a power of
resisting by which everybody as much as
in it lies continues in its present
state whether it be of rest or of moving
uniformly fourths in a right line this
force is always proportional to the body
whose force it is and differs nothing
from the inactivity of the mass but in
our manner of conceiving it a body from
the inert nature of matter is not
without difficulty put out of its state
of rest or motion upon which account
this vision Sita may by a most
significant name be called inertia or a
force of inactivity but a body only
exerts this force when another force
impressed upon it endeavours to change
its condition and the exercise of this
force may be considered as both
resistance and impulse it is resistance
so far as the body for maintaining its
present state opposes the force and
pressed it is impulse so far as the body
by not easily giving way to the
impressed force of another endeavours to
change the state of that other
resistance is usually ascribed to bodies
at rest and impulse to those in motion
but motion and rest as commonly
conceived are only relatively
distinguished nor are those bodies
always truly at rest which commonly are
taken to be so definition for an
impressed force as an action exerted
upon a body in order to change its state
either of rest or of uniform motion in a
right line this force consists in the
action only and remains no longer in the
body when the action is over for a body
maintains every new state it acquires by
its inertia only but impressed forces
are of different origin
as from percussion from pressure from
centripetal force definition v a
centripetal force is that by which
bodies are drawn or impelled or any way
tend towards a point as to a center of
this sword as gravity by which bodies
tend to the center of the earth
magnetism by which iron tends to the
lodestone and that force whatever it is
by which the planets are continually
drawn aside from the rectilinear motions
which otherwise they would pursue and
made to revolve in curvilinear orbits a
stone whirled about in a sling endeavors
to recede from the hand that turns it
and by that endeavor distends the sling
and that with so much the greater force
as it has revolved with the greater
velocity and as soon as it has let go
flies away that force which opposes
itself to this endeavor and by which the
sling continually draws back the stone
towards the hand and retains it in its
orbit because it is directed to the hand
as the center of orbit I call the
centripetal force and the same thing is
to be understood of all bodies revolved
in any orbits they all endeavour to
recede from the centres of their orbits
and were not for the opposition of a
contrary force which restrains them to
and detains them in their orbits which I
therefore call center people would fly
off in right lines with a uniform motion
a projectile if it was not for the force
of gravity would not deviate towards the
earth but would go off from it in a
right line and that with a uniform
motion if the resistance of the air was
taken away it is by its gravity that it
is drawn aside continually from its
rectilinear course and made
deviate towards the earth more or less
according to the force of its gravity
and the velocity of its motion unless
it's gravity is or the quantity of its
matter or the greater the velocity with
which it is projected the less it will
deviate from a rectilinear course and
the father who won't go if a leaden ball
projected from the top of a mountain by
the force of gunpowder with a given
velocity and in a direction parallel to
the horizon is carried in a curved line
to the distance of two miles before it
falls to the ground the same if the
resistance of air were taken away with a
double or DIC neutral velocity would fly
twice or ten times as far and by
increasing the velocity we may at
pleasure increase the distance to which
it might be projected and diminish the
curvature of the line which it might
describe until at last it should fall at
the distance of 10 30 or 90 degrees or
even might go quite around the whole
earth before it falls or lastly so that
it might never fall to the earth but go
forwards and to the celestial spaces and
proceed in its motion in infinitum and
after the same manner that our
projectile by the force of gravity may
be made to revolve in an orbit and go
round the whole earth the moon also
either by the force of gravity if it has
indeed with gravity or by any other
force that impels it towards the Earth
may be continually drawn aside towards
the earth out of the rectilinear way
which by its innate force it would
pursue and would be made to revolve in
the orbit which it now describes nor
could the moon without some such force
be retained in its orbit if this force
was too small it would not sufficiently
turn the
out of a rectilinear course if it was
too great it would turn it too much and
draw down the moon from its orbit
towards the Earth it is necessary that
the force be of a just quantity and it
belongs to the mathematicians to find
the force that may serve exactly to
retain a body in a given orbit with a
given velocity and vice-versa to
determine the curvilinear way into which
a body projected from a given place with
a given velocity may be made to deviate
from its natural rick tyranny away by
means of a given force the quantity of
any centripetal force may be considered
as of three kinds absolute accelerative
and motive
definition six the absolute quantity of
a centripetal force is the measure of
the same proportional to the efficacy of
the cause that propagates it from the
center through the spaces roundabout
thus the magnetic force is greater in
one loadstone and less in another
according to their sizes and strength of
intensity definition 7 the accelerative
quantity of a centripetal force is the
measure of the same proportional to the
velocity which it generates in a given
time thus the force of the same
lodestone is greater at a less distance
and less at a greater also the force of
gravity is greater in valleys less on
tops of exceeding high mountains and yet
less as shall hereafter be shown at
greater distances from the body of the
earth but at equal distances it is the
same everywhere because taking away or
allowing for the resistance of the air
it equally accelerates all falling
bodies where they're heavy or light
great or small definition 8 the motive
quantity of the centripetal force is the
measure of the same proportional to the
motion which it generates in a given
time
thus the weight is greater in a greater
body less in a less body and in the same
body it is greater near to the earth and
less at remoter distances the sort of
quantity is the centripetal sea or
propensity of the whole body towards the
center or as I may say its weight and it
has always known by the quantity of an
equal and contrary force just sufficient
to hinder the descent of the body these
quantities of forces we may for the sake
of brevity called by the names of motive
accelerative and absolute forces and for
the sake of distinction consider them
with respect to the bodies that tend to
the center to the places of those bodies
and to the center of force towards which
they tend that is to say I refer the
motive force to the body as an endeavor
and propensity of the whole towards a
center arising from the propensity z' of
the several paths taken together the
accelerator of force to the place of the
body as a certain power diffused from
the center to all places around to move
the bodies that are in them and the
absolute force to the center as endued
with some cause without which these
motor forces would not be propagated
through the spaces around about whether
that cause be some central body such as
is the magnet and the center of the
magnetic force or the earth in the
center of the gravitating force or
anything else that does not yet appear
for I here design only to give a
mathematic
notion of these forces without
considering their physical causes and
seats where for the accelerative force
and stand in the same relation to the
motive as celerity does to motion for
the quantity of motion arises from the
celerity multiplied by the quantity of
matter and the motor force arises from
the accelerator force multiplied by the
same quantity of matter for the sum of
the actions of the accelerator force
upon the several particles of the body
it is the motive force of the whole
hence it is that near the surface of the
earth where the accelerate of gravity or
force producer of gravity in all bodies
is the same the motive gravity of the
weight is as the body but if we should
ascend to higher regions where the
accelerator of gravity is less the
weight would be equally diminished and
would always be as the product of the
body by the accelerate of gravity so in
those regions where the accelerator of
gravity is diminished into one half the
weight of a body two or three times less
will be four or six times less i
likewise call attractions and impulses
in the same sense accelerative and
motive and use the words attraction
impulse or propensity of any sort
towards the center promiscuously and
indifferently one for another
considering those forces not physically
but mathematically where for the reader
is not to imagine that by those words i
anywhere take upon me to define the kind
or the manner of any action the causes
or the physical reasons thereof or that
I attribute forces in a true and physic
since to certain centers which are only
mathematical points when at any time I
happen to speak of centers as attracting
or as endued with attractive powers
Scullion hitherto I have laid down the
definitions of such words as are less
known and explained the sense in which I
would have them to be understood in the
following discourse I do not define time
space place and motion as being well
known to all only I must observe that
the common people conceived those
quantities under no other notions but
from the relation they bear to sensible
objects and thence arise certain
prejudices for the removing of which it
will be convenient to distinguish them
into absolute and relative true and
apparent mathematical and common one
absolute true and mathematical time of
itself and from its own nature flows
equally without relation to anything
external and by another name is called
duration relative apparent and common
time is some sensible and external
whether accurate or unequal measure of
duration by the means of motion which is
commonly used instead of true time such
as hour a day a month a year to absolute
space in its own nature without relation
to anything external remains always
similar and immovable relative space is
some movable dimension or measure of the
absolute spaces which are sensors
determined by its position two bodies
and which has commonly taken for a
moveable space
such is the dimension of a subterraneous
an aerial or celestial space determined
by its position and respect of the earth
absolute and relative space are the same
in Figure and magnitude but they do not
remain always a miracle II the same for
of the earth
for instance moves a space of our air
which relatively and in respect of the
earth remains always the same will at
one time a part of the absolute space
into which the air passes at another
time it will be another part of the same
and so absolutely understood it will be
continually changed three place is a
part of space which a body takes up and
is according to the space either
absolute or relative I say a part of
space not the situation nor the external
surface of the body for the places of
equal solids are always equal but their
surfaces by reason of their dissimilar
figures are often unequal positions
properly have no quantity nor are they
so much the places themselves as the
properties of places the motion of the
whole is the same with the sum of the
motions of the paths that is the
translation of the whole out of its
place is the same thing with the sum of
the translations of the parts out of
their places absolute time in astronomy
is distinguished from relative by the
equation or correction of the apparent
time for the natural days are truly
unequal though they are commonly
considered as equal and used for a
measure of time astronomers correct this
inequality so that they may measure the
celestial motions by a more accurate
time it may be that there is no such
thing as an equivalent whereby time may
be accurately measured all motions
may be accelerated and [ __ ] but the
flowing of absolute time is not liable
to any change the duration or
perseverance of the existence of all
things remains the same whether the
motions are Swift or slow or none at all
and therefore the situation ought to be
distinguished from what our only
sensible measures thereof and from which
we deduce it by means of the
astronomical equation the necessity of
this equation for determining the times
of a phenomenon is evidenced as well
from the experiments of the pendulum
clock as by eclipses of the satellites
of Jupiter as the order of the sum of
parts is immutable so also is the order
of the parts of space suppose those
parts to be moved out of their places
and they will be moved if the expression
may be allowed out of themselves four
times and spaces are as it were the
places as well of themselves as of all
other things all things are placed in
time as to order of succession and in
space
as the order of situation it is from
their essence or nature that they are
places and that the primary places of
things should be movable is absurd these
are therefore the absolute places and
translations out of those places are the
only absolute motions but because the
parts of space cannot be seen or
distinguished from one another by our
senses therefore in their steed we use
sensible measures of them for from the
positions and distances of things from
anybody considered as immovable we
define all places and then with respect
to such places we estimate all motions
considering bodies as transfer
from one of those places into others and
so instead of absolute places and
motions we use relative ones and that
without any inconvenience in common
affairs but in philosophical disposition
we ought to abstract from our senses and
consider things themselves distinct from
what our only sensible measures of them
for it may be that there is no body
really at rest to which the places and
motions of others may be referred but we
may distinguish rest and motion absolute
and relative one from the other by their
properties causes and effects it is a
property of rest that bodies really at
rest due west and respect to one another
and therefore as it is possible that in
the remote regions of the fixed stars or
perhaps far beyond them there may be
some body absolutely at rest but
impossible to know from the position of
bodies to one another in our regions
whether any of these do keep the same
position to that remote body it follows
that absolute rest cannot be determined
from the position of bodies in our
regions it is a property of motion at
the parts which retain given positions
to their holes do partake of the motions
of those holes for all the parts of
revolving bodies endeavor to recede from
the axis of motion and the impetus of
bodies moving fourths arises from the
joint impetus of all the parts therefore
if surrounding bodies are moved those
that are relatively at rest within them
will partake of the emotion upon which
account the true and absolute motion of
a body cannot be determined by the
translation of it from those which only
seem to rest for the external bodies
ought not only to appear at rest but to
be real
at West four otherwise all included
bodies besides their translations from
near the surrounding ones partake
likewise of their emotions and though
that translation were not made they
would not be really at rest but only
seemed to be so for the surrounding
bodies stand in the like relation to the
surrounded as the exterior part of a
whole does to the interior or as the
shell does to the kernel but if the
shell moves the kernel will also move as
being part of the whole without any
removal from near the shell a property
near akin to the proceeding is this that
the place is moved whatever is placed
therein moves along with it and
therefore a body which has moved from a
place in motion / takes also of the
motion of its place upon which account
all motions from places in motion are no
other than parts of entire and absolute
motions and every entire motion is
composed of the motion of the body out
of its first place and the motion of
this place out of its place and so on
until we come to some a movable place
where for entire and absolute motions
can be no otherwise determined than by
immovable places and for that reason I
did before refer those absolute motions
to immovable places but relative ones to
movable places now no other places ah
removable but those that from infinity
to infinity
do all retain the same given position
one to another and upon this account
must ever remain unmoved and do thereby
constitute available space the causes by
which true and relative motions are
distinguished one from the other are the
forces impressed upon body
used to generate motion true motion is
neither generated nor altered but by
some force impressed upon the body moved
but relative motion may be generated or
altered without any force impressed upon
the body for it is sufficient only to
impress some force on other bodies with
which the former is compared that by
their giving way that relation may be
changed in which the relative rest or
motion of this other body did consist
again true motion suffers always some
change from any force impressed upon the
moving body but relative motion does not
necessarily undergo any change by such
forces for if the same forces are
likewise impressed on those other bodies
with which the comparison is made that
the relative position may be preserved
then that condition will be preserved in
which the relative motion consists and
therefore any relative motion may be
changed when the true motion remains
unaltered and the relative may be
preserved when the true suffers some
change
thus true motion by no means consists in
any such relations the effects which
distinguish absolute from relative
motion are the forces of receding from
the axis of circular motion for there
are no such forces in a circular motion
purely relative but in a true and
absolute circular motion they are
greater or less according to the
quantity of the motion if a vessel hung
by a long cord is so often turned about
that the cord is strongly twisted then
filled with water and held at rest
together with the water thereupon by the
sudden action of another force it is
world about the contrary way
and while the cord
untwisting itself the vessel continues
for some time in this motion the surface
of the water will at first be playing as
before the vessel began to move but
after that the vessel by gradually
communicating its motion to the water
will make it begins sensibly to evolve
and recede by little and little from the
middle and ascend to the sides of the
vessel forming itself into a concave
figure as I have experienced and the
swifter the motion becomes the higher
will the water rise till at last
performing its revolutions in the same
times with the vessel it becomes
relatively at rest in it this ascent of
water shows its endeavor to recede from
the axis of its motion and the true and
absolute circular motion of the water
which is here directly contrary to the
relative becomes known and may be
measured by this endeavor at first when
the relative motion of the water in the
vessel was greatest it produced no
endeavor to recede from the axis the
water showed no tendency to the
circumference nor any ascent towards the
sides of the vessel but remained of a
plain surface and therefore its circular
motion had not yet begun but afterwards
when the relative motion of the water
had decreased the assent thereof towards
the sides of the vessel proved its
endeavored to recede from the axis and
thus endeavour showed the real circular
motion of the water continually
increasing till it had acquired its
greatest quantity when the water rested
relatively in the vessel and therefore
this endeavor does not depend upon any
translation of the water in respect of
the ambient bodies nor control circular
motion be defined by such translation
there is only one wheel circular motion
of any one revolving body corresponding
to only
power of endeavouring to recede from its
axis of motion as its proper and
adequate effect but relative motions in
one and the same body are innumerable
according to the various relations it
bears two external bodies and like the
other relations are altogether desperate
of any real effect any other wise then
they may perhaps partake of that one
only true motion and therefore in their
system who suppose that our heavens
revolving below the sphere of the fixed
stars carry the planets along with them
the several parts of those heavens and
the planets which are indeed relatively
at rest in their heavens do yet really
move for they change their position one
to another which never happens to bodies
truly at rest and being carried together
with their heavens partake of their
motions and as parts of revolving holes
endeavour to recede from the axis of
their motions where for relative
quantities are not the quantities
themselves whose names they bear but
those sensible measures of them either
accurate or inaccurate which are
commonly used instead of the measured
quantities themselves and if the meaning
of words is to be determined by their
use then by their names
time-space place in motion their
sensible measures are properly to be
understood and the expression will be
unusual and purely mathematical if the
measured quantities themselves are meant
on this account those violate the
accuracy of language which ought to be
kept precise who interpret these words
for the measured quantities nor do those
less defile the purity of mathematical
and philosophical truths who confound
real quantities with their relations and
sensible measures
it is indeed a matter of great
difficulty to discover and effectually
to distinguish the true motions of
particular bodies from the apparent
because the parts of that a moveable
space in which those motions are
performed do by no means come under the
observation of our senses yet the thing
is not altogether desperate for we have
some arguments to guide us partly from
the apparent motions which are the
differences of the true motions partly
from the forces which are the causes and
effects of the true motions for instance
if two globes kept at a given distance
one from the other by means of a cord
that connects them were revolved about
their common center of gravity we might
from the tension of the cord discover
the endeavor of the globes to recede
from the axis of their motion and from
thence we might compute the quantity of
their circular motions and then if any
equal forces should be impressed at once
only alternative phases of the globe's
to augment or diminish their circular
motions from the increase or decrease of
that tension of the cord we might infer
the increment or decrement of their
motions and thence would be found on
what phases those forces ought to be
impressed that the motions of the
globe's might be most augmented that is
we might discover their hindmost phases
or those which in the circular motion do
follow but the phases which follow being
known and consequently the opposite ones
that proceed we should likewise know the
determination of the emotions and thus
we might find both quantity and the
determination of the circular motion
even in an immense vacuum where there
was nothing external or sensible with
which the globe's could be compared but
now
in that space some remote bodies were
placed that kept always a given position
one to another as the fixed stars do in
our regions we could not indeed
determine from the relative translation
of the globes among those bodies whether
the motion did belong to the Globes or
to the bodies but if we observed the
chord and found that its tension was
that very tension which the motions of
the globes required we might conclude a
motion to be in our globes and the
bodies to be at rest and then lastly
from the translation of the globes among
the bodies we should find the
determination of their motions but how
we are to obtain the true motions from
their causes effects and apparent
differences and the converse shall be
explained more at large in the following
treatise for to this end it was that I
composed it axioms or laws of motion law
one everybody continues in its state of
rest or of uniform motion in a right
line unless it is compelled to change
that state by forces impressed upon it
projectiles continue in their motions so
far as they are not [ __ ] by the
resistance of the air or impelled
downwards by the force of gravity atop
whose parts by their cohesion are
continually drawn aside from rectilinear
motions
does not cease its rotation otherwise
then as it has [ __ ] by the air the
greater bodies of the planets and comets
meeting with less resistance and freer
spaces preserve their motions both
progressive and circular for a much
longer time law too
the change of motion is proportional to
the motive force and pressed and is made
in the direction of the right line in
which that force is impressed if any
force generates a motion a double force
will generate double the motion a triple
force tripled the motion whether that
forced be impressed all together and at
once more gradually and successively and
this motion being always directed the
same way with the generating force if
the body moved before is added to or
subtracted from the former motion
according as they directly conspire
worth or are directly contrary to each
other or obliquely joined when they are
oblique so as to produce a new motion
compounded from the determination of
both law 3 to every action there is
always opposed an equal reaction or the
mutual actions of two bodies upon each
other are always equal and directed to
contrary parts whatever drawers or
presses another is as much drawn or
pressed by that other if you press a
stone with your finger the finger is
also pressed by the stone if a horse
draws a stone tied to a rope the horse
if I may so say will be equally drawn
back towards the stone for the dist
hindered rope by the same endeavor to
relax or unbend itself will draw the
horse as much towards the stone as it
does the stone towards the horse and
will obstruct the progress of the one as
much as it advances that of the other if
a body impinge upon another and by its
force change the motion of the other
that body also because of the equality
of the mutual pressure will undergo an
equal change in its own motion towards
the contrary part
changes made by these actions are equal
not in the velocities but in the motions
of bodies that is to say if the bodies
are not hindered by any other
impediments for because the motions are
equally changed the changes of the
velocities made towards the contrary
parts are inversely proportional to the
bodies this law takes place also in
attractions as will be proved in the
next Scullion corollary 1 a body acted
on by two forces simultaneously will
describe the diagonal of a parallelogram
in the same time as it would describe
the sides by those forces separately
corollary 2 and hence as explained the
composition of any one direct force ad
out of any two oblique forces AC and CD
and on the contrary the resolution of
any one direct force ad into two oblique
forces a C and C D which composition and
resolution are abundantly confirmed from
mechanics corollary 3 the quantity of
motion which is obtained by taking the
sum of motions directed towards the same
parts and the difference of those that
are directed to contrary parts suffers
no change from the action of bodies
amongst themselves corollary for the
common center of gravity of two or more
bodies does not alter its state of
motion or West by the actions of the
bodies among themselves and therefore
the common center of gravity of all
bodies acting upon each other
excluding external actions and
impediments is either at rest or moves
uniformly in a
it's line corollary five the motions of
bodies included in a given space are the
same among themselves whether that space
is at rest or moves uniformly forwards
in a writes line without any circular
motion corollary six if bodies moved in
any matter among themselves are urged in
the direction of parallel lines by equal
accelerative forces they will all
continue to move among themselves after
the same manner as if they had not been
urged by those forces Scullion hitherto
I have laid down such principles as have
been received by mathematicians and are
confirmed by abundance of experiments by
the first two laws and the first two
corollaries Galileo discovered that the
descent of bodies varied as the square
of the time and that the motion of
projectiles was in the curve of a
parabola experience agreeing with both
unless so far as these motions are a
little [ __ ] by the resistance of the
air when a body is falling the uniform
force of its gravity acting equally
impressive and equal intervals of time
equal forces upon that body and
therefore generates equal velocities and
in the whole time and presses a whole
force and generates a whole velocity
proportional to the time and the space
is described in proportional times R as
the product of the velocities and the
times that is as the squares of the
times and when a body is thrown upwards
its uniform gravity impresses forces and
reduces velocity is proportional to the
times and the times
ascending to the greatest heights are as
the velocities to be taken away and
those heights are as the product of the
velocities and the times or as the
squares of the velocities and if a body
be projected in any direction the motion
arising from its projection is
compounded with the motion arising from
its gravity thus if the body a by its
motion of projection alone could
describe in a given time the right line
a B and with its motion of falling alone
could describe in the same time the
altitude a see complete the
parallelogram a b c d and the body by
that compounded motion will at the end
of the time be found in the place d and
the curved line AE d which that body
describes will be a parabola to which
the right line a B will be tangent at a
and whose ordinate B D will be as the
square of the line a B on the same laws
and corollary x' depend those things
which have been demonstrated concerning
the times of the vibration of pendulums
and are confirmed by the daily
experiments of pendulum clocks by the
same together with law 3 Sir Christopher
Wren dr. Wallace and mr. Huygens the
greatest geometers of our times did
severally determine the rules of the
impact and reflection of hard bodies and
about the same time communicated their
discoveries to the Royal Society
exactly agreeing among themselves as to
those rules dr. Wallace indeed was
somewhat earlier in the publication then
followed Sir Christopher
when and lastly mr. Hagen's butts if
Christopher win confirmed the truth of
the thing before the Royal Society by
the experiments on pendulums which in
Mariette soon after a thought fit to
explain in a treatise entirely upon that
subject but to bring this experiment to
an accurate agreement with theory we are
to have due regard as well to the
resistance of air as to the elastic
force of the concurring bodies let the
spherical bodies a B be suspended by the
parallel and equal strings a c ee d from
the Centers C and D about these centres
with those links as radii describe the
semicircles EA f g bh bisected
respectively by the radii CA d be bring
the body a to any point R of the arc EAS
and withdrawing the body B let it go
from thence and after one oscillation
suppose it to return to the point V then
our V will be the retardation arising
from the resistance of the air of this
RV let s T be a fourth part situated in
the middle namely so that our s is equal
to t v and r s to s T is equal to three
to two then we'll st represent very
nearly the retardation during the
descent from s to a restore the body b
to its place and supposing the body a to
be lit for from the bottom from the
point s the velocity thereof and the
place of reflection
without sensible error will be the same
as if it had descended in vacuo from the
point T upon which account this velocity
may be represented by the chord of the
arc ta 4 it is a proposition well known
to geometers that the velocity of a
pendulous body in the lowest point is as
the chord of the arc which it has
described in its descent after
reflection suppose the body a comes to
the place s and the body b to the place
k withdraw the body b and find the place
v from which if the body a being let go
should after 1 oscillation return to the
place r st may be a fourth part of our V
so placed in the middle thereof as to
leave RS equal to T V and let the chord
of the arc ta
represent the velocity which the body a
had in the place a immediately after
reflection 14 will be the true and
correct place to which the body a should
have ascended if the resistance of the
air had been taken off in the same way
we are to correct the place K to which
the body be a sins by finding the place
l2 which it should have ascended in
vacuo and thus everything may be
subjected to experiment in the same
manner as if we were really placed in
vacuo these things being done we are to
take the product if I may so say of the
body a by the chord of the arc ta which
represents its velocity that we may have
its motion in the place a immediately
before reflection and then by the chord
of the arc ta that we may have its
motion in the place
immediately after reflection and so we
are to take the product of the body be
by the cord of the RPL that we may have
the emotion of the same immediately
after affliction and in like manner when
two bodies are let go together from
different places we are to find the
motion of each as well before as after
affliction and then we may compare the
motions between themselves and collect
the effects of the reflection thus
trying the thing with pendulums of ten
feet and unequal as well as equal bodies
and making the bodies to concur after it
descent through large spaces as an eight
twelve or sixteen feet
I found always without an error of three
inches that when the bodies concurred
together directly equal changes towards
the contrary parts were produced in the
emotions and of consequence that the
action and reaction were always equal as
if the body a and pinched upon the body
be at rest with nine parts of motion and
losing seven proceeded after affliction
with two the body was carried backwards
with those seven parts if the body is
concurred with contrary motions he with
twelve parts of motion and E with six
then if a were seated with two he was
seated with eight namely with a
deduction of fourteen parts of motion on
each side far from the motion of a
subtracting twelve parts nothing will
remain from subtracting two parts more
emotion will be generated of two parts
towards the contrary way and so from the
motion of body B of six parts
subtracting fourteen parts
a motion is generated of eight parts
towards the contrary away
but if the bodies were made both to move
towards the same way a the swifter with
14 parts of motion be the slower with
five and after reflection a went on with
five he likewise went on with 14 parts
nine parts being transferred from A to B
and so in other case by the meeting and
collision of bodies the quantity of
motion obtained from the sum of the
motions directed towards the same way or
from the difference of those that were
directed towards contrary ways was never
changed for the era of an inch or two
and missions may be easily ascribed to
the difficulty of executing everything
with accuracy it was not easy to let go
the two pendulums so exactly that
together that the bodies should impinge
one upon the other in the lowermost
place a B nor to mark the places s and K
to which the bodies sinned after impact
name and some errors too might have
happened from the unequal density of the
parts of the pendulous bodies themselves
and from the irregularity of the texture
proceeding from other causes but to
prevent an objection that may perhaps be
alleged against the rules for the proof
of which this experiment was made as if
this rule did suppose that the bodies
were either absolutely hard or at least
perfectly elastic whereas no such bodies
are found in nature I must add that the
experiments we have been describing by
no means depending upon that equality of
hardness do succeed as well in soft as
in hard bodies for if the rule is to be
tried in bodies not perfectly hard we
are only to diminish thereof
election in such a certain proportion as
the quantity of the elastic force
requires by the theory of Wren and
Huygens bodies absolutely had returned
one from another with the same velocity
with which they meet but this may be
affirmed with more certainty of bodies
perfectly elastic in bodies perfectly
elastic the velocity of the return is to
be diminished together with the elastic
force because that force except when the
parts of bodies are bruised by their
impact or suffer some such extension as
happens under the strokes of a hammer is
as far as I can perceive certain
undetermined and makes the bodies to
return one from the other with a
relative velocity which is in a given
ratio to the relative velocity which
they met this I tried in balls of wool
made up tightly and strongly compressed
for first by letting though the
pendulous bodies and measuring their
reflection I determined the quantity of
their elastic force and then according
to this force estimated their
afflictions that ought to happen in
other cases of impact and with this
computation other experiments made
afterwards did accordingly agree the
balls always receiving one from the
other with a relative velocity which was
to the relative velocity with which they
met as about five to nine balls of steel
returned with almost the same velocity
those of cork were the velocity
something less but in balls of glass the
proportion was as about 15 to 16 and
thus the third law so far as it regards
percussions and reflections is proved by
a theory exactly agreeing with
experience
attractions I briefly demonstrate the
thing after this manner suppose an
obstacle is interposed to hinder the
meeting of any two bodies a be
attracting one the other then if either
body as a is more attracted towards the
other body B then that body B is towards
the first body a the obstacle will be
more strongly urged by the pressure of
the body a and by the pressure of the
body B and therefore will not remain in
equilibrium but the stronger pressure
will prevail and will make the system of
the two bodies together with the
obstacle to move directly towards the
parts on which be lies and in free
spaces to go forwards in infinitum with
emotion continually accelerated which is
absurd and contrary to the first law for
by the first law the system ought to
continue in its state of rest or of
moving uniformly fords in a right line
and therefore the bodies must equally
press the obstacle and be equally
attracted one by the other
I made the experiment on the lodestone
and iron if these placed apart in proper
vessels I made to float by one another
in standing water neither of them will
propel the other but by being equally
attracted they will sustain each other's
pressure and rest at last in an
equilibrium so the gravitation between
the earth and its parts is mutual with
the earth if I be cut by any plane eg
into two parts EGS and eg I and their
weights one towards the other will be
mutually equal for F by another plane HK
parallel to the former EQ the greater
part e GI is cut into two
EG k h and h ki where of h ki is equal
to the part EF g first cut off it is
evident at the middle part EG k h will
have no prepend by its proper weight
towards either side but will hang as it
were and rest in an equilibrium between
both but the one extreme part h ki will
with its whole weight thereupon and
press the middle part towards the other
extreme part EG f and therefore the
force with which EG i the sum of the
parts h ki and EG k h tend towards the
third part e GF is equal to the weight
of the pod h ki that is to the weight of
the third part in gf and therefore the
weights of the two parts EG i and EG if
one towards the other are equal as i was
to prove and indeed if those weights
were not equal the whole earth floating
in the non resisting ether would give
way to the greater weight and retiring
from it would be carried off in
infinitum and as those bodies are
equally potent in the impact and
reflection whose velocities are
inversely as their innate forces so in
the use of mechanic instruments those
agents are equivalent and mutually
sustain each the contrary pressure of
the other whose velocities estimated
according to the determination of the
forces are inversely as the forces so
those weights are of equal force to move
the arms of the balance which during the
play of the balance are inversely as
their velocities upwards and downwards
that is
if the ascent or descent is direct those
weights are of equal force which are
inversely as the distances of the points
at which they are suspended from the
axis of the balance but if they are
turned aside by the interposition of
oblique planes or other obstacles and
made to ascend or descend obliquely
those bodies will be equivalent which
are inversely as the heights of their
ascent and decent taken accordingly to
the perpendicular and that on account of
the determination of gravity downwards
and in like manner in the pulley or in a
combination of pulleys the force of a
hand and drawing the rope directly which
is to the weight where there are sending
directly or obliquely as the velocity of
the perpendicular ascent of the weight
to the velocity of the hand that draws
the Rope will sustain the weight in
clocks and suchlike instruments made up
from a combination of wheels the
contrary forces that promote and impede
the motion of the wheels if they are
inversely as the velocities of the parts
of the wheel on which they are impressed
will mutually sustain each other the
force of the screw to press a body is to
the force of the hand that turns the
handles by which it is moved as the
circular velocity of the handle in that
part where it is impelled by the hand is
to the progressive velocity of the screw
towards the pressed body the forces by
which the wedge presses or drives the
two parts of the wood it Cleaves R to
the force of the mallet upon the wedge
as the progress of the wedge in the
direction of the force impressed upon it
by the mallet is to the velocity with
which the parts of the wood yield to the
wedge in the direction of lines
perpendicular to the sides of the wedge
and the light account is to be given of
machines the power and use of machines
consists only in this that by
diminishing the velocity we may augment
the force and the contrary from whence
in all sorts of proper machines we have
the solution of this problem to move a
given weight with a given power or with
a given force to overcome any other
given resistance for if machines are so
contrived that the velocities of the
agent and resistant are inversely as
their forces and that the agent will
just sustain the resistance but with a
greater disparity of velocity will
overcome it so that if the disparity of
velocities is so great as to overcome
all that resistance which commonly
arises either from the friction of
contentious bodies as they slide by one
another or from the cohesion of
continuous bodies that are to be
separated or from the weights of bodies
to be raised the excess of the force
remaining after all those resistances
are overcome will produce an
acceleration of motion proportional
thereto as well in the part of the
machine as in the resisting body but to
treat of mechanics is not my present
business I was aiming only to show by
these examples the great extent
uncertainty of the third law of motion
for if we estimate the action of the
agent from the product of its force and
velocity and likewise the reaction of
the impediment from the product of the
velocities of its several parts and the
forces of resisting arising from the
friction cohesion weight and
acceleration of those parts the action
and reaction in the use of all sorts of
machines will be found always equal to
one another and so far
the action is propagated by the
intervening instruments and at last
impressed upon the resisting body the
ultimate action will always be contrary
to the reaction